what's with the jeans that is impression
of the housekeeping services at the
hotel we're staying at yes in Las Vegas
do you want to do an undisclosed
location well you know maybe we'll get
to it we'll get to it this morning we
awoke to just I mean screaming would you
get you what you which happens in Vegas
really yeah but in Vegas you you're kind
of like there's people are gonna be
noisy yeah but it took two but maybe the
third or fourth yell to be like oh wait
a minute that's not drunk people fix
some ring down the hall
yeah that's housekeeping yelling down
the hall at each other the people who
work here people that work here we're
literally like what the fuck it sounds
like it went on for hours it sounds a
little bit like and I don't mean to
throw stones at your impressions it
sounds a little bit like the coach for
the Florida team oh that you like I mean
your impression just sounded similar I
know you're still working on it
and stuff but it did so you think it's
not like Coach ice yeah mmm a little bit
well here's something you don't know
yeah I went out there coach ice is
cleaning now know what you have good
ears
maybe he got fired from his coaching gig
there's no way no one could ever let
coach ice go can I tell you we've gotten
so many tweets and positive feedback
about that episode about the of Tom's
impression of the coach that I think it
may become
staple on your mom's house yeah well you
know here's something you don't know I
got an email from an executive about an
animated show yeah I didn't so I can't
say what I'll tell you when we're done
about doing a voice that he liked that
I've done before in the in comedy yeah
and then I I suggested that he give let
me my my coach ice force for him so
there now I told him I go it's the voice
that he liked I go it's a good voice but
I have another one I want to show you
can I tell you nothing would make me
prouder as your wife and as a fellow
comedian is if you got cast playing a
black person essentially as a voiceover
voiceover yeah that would be that would
be a triumph
well that would fill me with joy you
can't really you know we haven't even
started officially no I mean I realize
that we haven't even said we are this is
guys oh well welcome to your mom's house
mom's back there's two mummies in the
house now we never do some solo nope you
did because wait you listen well here's
what happened we had to do I think one
episode without you because you were
sick dude you were deathly ill we're not
fucking around that is that's the most
sick I've been in I mean really in it as
long as I can remember it was borderline
going I mean I went to the doctor yes
almost ended up going to a specialist
and I really fucked myself I got really
sick I basically on it on a Tuesday
night I did two shows and no at one show
I did a show in Irvine on Tuesday on a
Tuesday night the next day Wednesday I
woke up really fucking sick yeah oh and
I I canceled some stuff that day but I'd
still went that night and did a show in
town and the next day I went to San
Francisco with Joe Rogan and Sam Tripoli
and did a weekend at Cobbs with them and
I mean it was just I was progressively
getting worse I mean really bad to the
point where Saturday I was you know I
definitely I mean without question
should not have been doing shows and I
ended up I ended up getting Joe sick on
the on the trip and then Sam got a
little sick but I got I got Joe about as
sick as almost as sick as I was like he
was he was telling you got me sick a
little and I couldn't go it's hard yeah
yeah but I'm saying to her doing the
progression right cuz I was gone first I
got the second one on the road
immediately so when I got I got home
from from San Francisco I had a couple
days yes off where I went to the doctor
immediately I was like I mean we're
talking like sinus congestion can't hear
tons of green snot anal bleeding and the
but the real thing was the lungs
I had like chest I was breathing you
could hear all the flimsy barking
everything went to the doctor he was
like bronchial she doesn't sound good he
gave him medicine and like an idiot I
went on the road three days later I did
a full weekend of shows at the Newport
funny bone which is just south of
Cincinnati 6 shows flew back Monday and
then you started showing signs like on
that Monday and then Tuesday night had
to take the red-eye yeah so by Tuesday
we were coughing you were sick and I was
like there's basically like I knew from
my experience of doing the shows that's
sick how bad it got so I knew like you
were just gonna get worse - so you like
a smart person stay at home but I got
multiple texts from Jose like you fucked
me up like devastating but I know we I
feel like everybody could learn
something and I'm yeah we're getting on
a health trip right now yeah well you
know what I think I think we know last
week's dental arch is this week's
HealthWatch let's talk about health
here's what I what I learned from
getting that sick what did you learn
time it took me thirty two years to
figure this out yes first of all your
body gives you signals listen to them
yeah the first one is the first one is
when your body needs rest you need to
rest that's right I pushed through that
as I have always done and just got
progressively worse oh yeah the second
one is to take better care of myself
exercise and sleep those are the things
vitamins exercise slow down that I
really I really pulled back on jerking
off for the first for the first two
weeks you feel better much better yeah I
usually masturbate a lot when I'm a
second worse you can't force it out like
that you have to reserve your body's
resources yes now you can fight sickness
with your mind sometimes you and I'm a
Jedi you're incredible can I tell you
that I thought I had beaten this one
with my mind you did think you had and I
did not but but usually can in the years
that I have known you yes Calvin it is
actually one of the most impressive and
frustrating things that I've witnessed
because I have a weak low t-cell count
immune system but I guess I guess I get
sick sick you get sick once a week no I
don't know I don't know I guess like
like colds yeah twice a year it's
because of your t-cell count right yeah
but twice a year let's be clear twice a
year I get you know either it could go
or do go to the doctor say but you go to
the doctor more than most people know I
know yes you do well you go to the
doctor a lot like what do you mean a lot
like when something's wrong they go to
the doctor like what like oh I have
chest pains instead of ignoring them
yeah look you're supposed to like I do
you go to the doctor
they tell you shit like I don't know
though the best thing to do is ignore it
if you ignore something long enough it
goes away that is good at save money
that is good advice
we just heard somebody screaming did you
do that yeah but that wasn't made I was
just gonna come in this house keeping
that was who needs shampoo how do you um
you know but I don't believe in doctors
because they lie and they don't know
what the fuck they're talking about but
here's the truth what's the truth I to
me the thing that I'm the most obsessed
with doctor like stuff about yeah it
like there's like a sinus infection for
me and that's what I always go I go if I
feel like others green snot and I can't
breathe I fucking go to the doctor can I
tell you if that is wise because my mom
used to tell me if it's green I'd say
infection of course and you'll have to
go to the doctor you have to get
medication yeah penicillin yeah where
the thing is your body now with these
antibiotics builds up a resistance to
penicillin and that's why they're
creating all these strands like
amoxicillin and that data cylinder
because the human body is becoming too
resilient to penicillin yeah so you got
to be careful we have to choose when you
want to take that shit yeah it's a
bummer it's just a bummer being sick but
what does it do yeah
like the Phoenix you rise from the ashes
of your sickness yeah you have a new
lease on life on love yeah and you feel
better after you're down for a week you
really value the little things in life
right like taking it down you enjoy a
lot more absolutely like watching small
children fall crying it makes you laugh
a lot more so true that when you go
through that feeling of being so sick
you appreciate everything will you value
everything yeah because you're reborn
again a cup of coffee
oh you're just man tasting just tasting
yep you get to taste coming what I miss
the most when I'm sick is eating Mexican
food
because I don't know if you know this
listeners but I carry Tapatio in my car
I always have always for years just in
case I come across a taco a bland taco
that needs seasoning or flavoring and I
miss Mexican Clinton most sure I
remember when one time I picked
and he got in the car he was like just
like a fat guy like you to have hot
sauce before and I was like I guess
Christina he's like yeah sure
she's like dude it's Christina's like
now I'm liking heavier I show you how
exciting it was by the way I had for the
very first time in my life I tried
chick-fil-a Tom and I were driving to
Vegas dude yeah the south is what it's
all about that was your first check my
first chick-fil-a which I by the way
didn't know there was any like west of
the Mississippi other guys had any I
know I never grew up going horse I know
we stopped we happen to pull over
yeah all four to ten and my house
chick-fil-a Tommy got so excited It was
as if he had seen Jenna Jameson and
jenna haze scissoring each other watch
and it was was what's more exciting for
you know that was pretty good okay I do
remember when I told ya because I went
to call it no I'm saying I was in cotton
went to college in North Carolina know
what I'm say that chick-fil-a is is all
over the south like you know I've been
to Georgia groom Florida I don't know if
the Florida but anyways I've had a
chick-fil-a many times and when I saw it
I was like you got to go what do you
think I loved it here's what yes yes
enjoy it to grow Stevens
it's even Brody Stevens it's a
beautifully greasy filet and then it's
just just shitty bring shitty cheap way
off like and pickles and pickle now can
I tell you the bonus to all of us yeah
is that I went in to take a leak because
we were in the drive-thru because we're
lazy we don't even part to go in and I
went to make a number one a sissy and I
saw the arrangement of sauces they give
away like barbecue ranch and then the
shake away sauce get the fuck out of
here shut the front door
yeah I I couldn't believe it and I love
as a inner fat person I embrace my inner
fat person
sawsan I might stop at that shake fillet
on the way I can do that son I'm gonna
have it you're flying back oh shit oh
shit
your tits just got twisted thank you and
I have to go to fucking Middle East
let's discuss that for a moment can I
give can we give Hotel tips absolutely
let's well first of all so big problems
the chick-fil-a your big problem huge
fan yeah so you know artists index are
on the road all the time and we have
become professionals at and traveling
and staying on the road so we're gonna
give you guys a few tips for those few
times that you might go on the road this
will enhance your road happiness and you
know what it's about health we're in the
health now for health wealth and and
this is this is going to improve your
lifestyle your your you're gonna live a
happier life
first thing is always ask for if you go
to like one of those smaller like
hampton inn or anything like that the
first floor sometimes they'll be like oh
we have first foot like now i can't stay
on the first floor
fuck a first floor and you bet you might
think it's easy accent well there's a
couple reasons why you might think as
easy access well I don't want to have to
drive the elevator yes you do already
elevator first of all all those hotels
have free breakfasts 6 a.m. to 10:00
a.m. you know what happens a hundred and
fifty people go to that Lobby area and
the noise level goes I mean the noise
level is like the maids here is like
it's crazy loud people I don't know cuz
I get up for radio and you walk by
you're like oh holy shit
80 people in the lobby right now and
there's no way you can avoid not hearing
that so that's the reason number one you
don't want to be on the first floor
safety
what I would say is a woman traveling
alone first floor is never a good option
because of rape people follow you don't
follow you in people can climb in your
window today with Cox do it with Cox all
the time you know I just took an
anti-terrorist training thing on the
internet because I'm going to the Middle
East next week to entertain our troops
and and what they what I learned from
the terrorism training is that I told
you this one Tommy that you got to pick
a room in between the second and fifth
floor in case like they have to evacuate
you you can still be reached by a ladder
and don't get a room near the emergency
exits because people can like kidnap you
isn't that crazy
yeah please drink I like that one though
now can I give him my biggest tip this
is the most important tip by far the
dick tip the dick tip this is my most
and here's what I've learned this is
like that hands-on thing you do right
yes with a free internet no but here's
the thing the best tip I've ever learned
and this is just a matter of having the
gall to ask is that a lot of these
hotels have like fridges and microwaves
that they can give you in your room and
you can go to like a Trader Joe's if you
can use Yelp and see like what an
Englishman should heroes resort but we
like Trader Joe's because it's they have
salads prepackaged so you can eat
healthy so you're not eating shit and
you can put your food in your fucking
fridge and then microwave your frozen
dinner listen I'm telling you and
especially if you do travel for work or
business yeah all that restaurant shit
it wreaks havoc on you after a while you
feel shitty your shits I'm a god to like
shit your shits they get to a point
where you know nothing's good anymore I
start I start crying during my shoes and
now because of the feeling because of
this things are bad can I tell you my
poo I was in Kansas City yeah and I had
ribs like three times a day because
that's all they eat is ribs that's good
that's a good that's a good diet it was
fantastic and I was like how do you guys
shit because when I made a brown town it
smelled like death you didn't and I've
had road shit before
Road ass this was like unprecedented
smells eyes tearing I thought I would
vomit on top of my poop pile that's I've
done it before
you vomited on top of your poo when
because the smell one time Shanna I
Memphis what a dream those ribs ribs
baby back ribs
don't lie well my baby back
Tony Romo's wait but I forgot to tell
you the thing ok they're gonna want to
charge you sometimes for these fridges
yes tell me how do we get out of it Tom
you need your fridge for medicine boom
bang hey oh and that can include weed
brownies we're just saying you can put
your way brownie yeah there's no rules
about that yeah
put the chain fridge oh and also it does
help to set your alarm and go down for
the buffet of like free breakfast save
some money you save some money
ya know you free to put in your pockets
I'll put all this shit you can take milk
and a cup and put it in your little
fridge and eat that later and when you
wake up absolutely you absolutely can do
that yeah man I'm trying to think of
another one I steal tons of soap we
haven't bought soap in our house in a
couple of years now
that shit's funny like my mother or
conditioner I know your mom feels a lot
of places raisi how dare you but it's
good to steal that's what it's there for
they want you to steal so we just gave
you those tips sooner insider tips
median tips yeah oh oh my gosh do you
hear that
that's that's the notice for a dental of
it came through I didn't hear it yeah
the here's the scoop the scoop is that
do you I guess you updated them well we
gotta let the fans know people have been
writing us know thank you for your
tweets about our did you do the last one
oh I wasn't there
you gave him the root canal update oh my
god did it cost me I cost me $1,300 just
freaking out an entire bucks for my
goddamn crown you tell them about the
breaking I think I did I was so
traumatized Tommy and I got a temporary
crown on and we're sitting there eating
macaroni with me to tell you you were
upset with me because oh yes this was
amazing so it was it was the denied
member I said I got sick Tuesday
Wednesday morning I woke up this was the
day one of officially being sick like
sick right like throat eyes nose that
was that's the day so that morning
you're like I'm going to have a root
canal and I'm like I'm sick as fuck and
you're like alright well stay here and
rest I want to go get this done yeah and
then later in the day like a woman today
you let it like said for a while and
you're like didn't come with me to get
my root because I was I know I was like
what I'm sick and you saw how ii ended
up getting and then I was like so I just
I needed to rest I didn't believe you at
the time there was only day one right I
thought you were faking like you always
what fake I fake thing really yeah
right so she was very like she was she
was very defensive very hostile and and
I was dying is that feel good no no how
dare you how dare you in
why then I don't brush and fly never
seen it she gets real defensive yeah and
she goes yeah you're unbelievable Sakura
here's what you do so I'm like am I
going I'm sick so you make macaroni and
cheese and you're like oh and guess is
cooking for you right now yeah I'm
taking care young PD because otherwise
you're not gonna feed yourself you
fuckin asshole yeah and you see you're
like you're insulted calling names I'm
I'm really like broken down physically
I'm you know I'm just tired worn down
emotionally broken down and I'm like I'm
like I'm just taking this abuse like
abuse abuse abuse like living with
living with Pol Pot usually call me know
our listeners what your nickname is for
me your nickname yeah which one but I
usually call you either no I mean I like
the idea that I'm so evil yeah I'm so
sinister than I am Hitler's propagandist
those I mean that's a more sinister than
Hitler himself is that I who masterminds
yeah there was like there couldn't be a
more accurate nickname for something so
I can't believe people are listening the
story and thinking that you're accurate
the story so then you're like I make you
numbnuts
I didn't just make you mac and cheese
what else was on oh yeah there was some
chili chili delicious healthy vegan
chili from Trader Joe's so then you go
yeah yeah the magnitude and then you got
like you throw it down
and by the way there's no more other
those coming over tomorrow but any other
so I'm like alright so I start eating
and and then you take a bite number one
and your eyes and then you open your
mouth and you take your 2004 tooth and
it was the crown the crown broke clean
and hours before and I don't know if
you've ever had a crown fall out it's
fucking horrifying yeah for me I have
nightmares about my teeth falling I'm
sure it's a common nightmare a lot of
people have but if you have nightmares
about your teeth falling out all the
time and to have your tooth fall out as
you're eating like your favorite thing
mac and cheese and white red chilli yeah
it's fucking horrifying sure and I was
like I wanted to cry I was just she was
fucking terrible yeah oh and you went
then the next day the next day like he
didn't say shit what it is is the guy
that did the root canal I remember this
he they give you like ten shots to do
I'm you yeah and he goes well let's just
see if I can pry this temp crown off and
then he takes some fucking pliers and
starts pulling on it and I know if he
had done one more tug it would have
popped off but he didn't want to pull so
hard so I think he just loosened it up
just enough whoa and he drilled a hole
through the top of the temp crown and
that's how he did the root canal and he
knows great is getting to watch it
through the guy's reflective lenses it's
so gross I took my picture and I okay so
I had a fucking it's embarrassing how
many fillings I had to have done okay on
the last one I wanted to make sure I had
gone for three appointments unfairly
misfortune and yeah oh my god so the
third time I said back there like I like
it cuz they were doing shit that I had
never had done before like like an
apparatus hanging like screwed onto my
tooth the metal thing hanging out of my
mouth and I was like I want to get a
picture of this so I grabbed my phone
procedure while he's doing he goes could
you not do that and like he's a very
like professional respectable dignified
man this doctor you thought that he's
fantastic and I'm like you could tell
he's like seriously yeah you fucking
piece of shit I was like he's like yeah
when you do that you move and I'm doing
something very precise here okay I
needed to be able to drill the tiniest
little hole and you don't realize you're
making involuntary movements with your
head and I was like oh like it's okay
look he forgave me it's okay so then now
then like he like he waited like he did
this thing then he goes I'm gonna take a
picture down that's fine so I go okay
okay it's okay
okay bring something up sidebar look I
had my eyebrows waxed and they look
amazing for the first time I like I find
how my eyebrows professionally likes and
now I'm extremely inspired to wax my
undercarriage and my ale and that's
going to be a future development a lot
of hair it's real course and curly real
hairy box it's just a forest you know
that's funny that's like the hairy bear
calling a hair pie hurry
you're a hairier I had my ass waxed on
national television
which was kind of a regret on the Bob
and Tom yeah on their show
but nice taste people some people were
like why would you do that and I was
like it was whatever I did it for the
radio and and then I was I guess stupid
I'm not kidding you as a really hairy
guy and if you're a hairy guy out there
and you're like yeah but I'm not doing
that the eight weeks following that yeah
the best shits of my life really
well that's clean less cleanup sure not
the shit no no but that should be more
fucking because I am being specific
gurbles I'm saying that no listeners
don't understand I'm saying my whole the
cross that I carry is wiping
like there's so much I mean you see how
hairy picture the the top of your head
if your head if you have had it hair on
your head
that's what my asshole looks like it's
that much air and so then picture
shitting on that every time I think
about what it takes to clean that up why
don't you use baby white I've done it
I've done it all I'm just saying that
you know what that it is a process it is
a you know ten fifteen white process and
I fucking knew it because I'm always
bitching to Tommy that we go through
toilet paper like a roll a day I'm not
even joking guys like I buy us like a
Twelver and that shit is gone and just a
little over a week and then when Tommy's
not in town and I'm home I do two takes
me like a week to plow through a roll of
toilet paper yeah Tommy because you just
you go and you go and you go yeah I'm
telling you but when I had the ass waxed
it was very silky man and then in the
steam the the you know the between the
cheeks when that was clean oh it was
like shitting like a normal person where
it's like shit and then wipe one two
three and then it was like oh I'm done
because there's not I didn't smear it
all over here I didn't smash that
frosting that frosting all over this
shit frosting so you know you're
thinking about that I'm thinking about
getting my bean bag and my shaft waxed
we gotta do it cuz there's a lot of hair
there too I'm gonna shave it all the
time but can I tell you one thing about
the Middle East by the way is that we
think that they're all dirty dirty dirt
bags they're not excuse me who thought
that I didn't think that oh really
maybe I am but I think the assumption
conserved the Arab world um they do have
that thing dirty dirt bags because they
wipe with their hands don't you never
supposed to touch the left hand because
you clean and it's true that they do and
what I understand well last time I was
there I was told that they they do in
fact wipe directly with the hand and
then they washed the hand now the thing
is is that I was in forget where Bahrain
and they have bidets everywhere yeah
so the bidet is actually where it's at
now they think it's repulsive that I'm
Americans smear shit on their asshole
with dry toilet paper to them that's
like why are you smearing the shit on
your butthole because I talked to this
guy over there and he said that yeah we
we rinse it directly with water or our
hands and that to them feels cleaner
than mashing it and I can kind of see
the logic in that
yeah but I prefer but damn I wish you
know I could see the logic didn't love a
good name you know I can see stoning a
woman to death for having sex with a man
not of her tribe how dare you I see that
logic how dare you know what you do
you talk to that let's get some rocks
those those handles you know when I
don't think this is funny and I'm gonna
go to the Middle East I'm gonna tell
jokes yeah that's really smart
so to clarify we don't think Middle
Eastern people are dirty dirtbags
no you know what I'm saying people
assume that they all live in tents and
ride camels again your statements you
ready so let's go you're about to leave
to the Middle East a few days I'm gonna
miss you I miss you too mommy jeans you
don't hear my main mommy this house is
gonna have one mommy when mommy and only
one pair of jeans yep but one salami
Tommy mommy probably touched my peepee
tell us you've been there before we've
been in I can't believe in here in the
Middle East for the second time I know I
think I'm I'm full of friends I'm going
with Sarah Tiana who was on our show
milestone last time was phenomenal and
great and this girl Jody Miller who's
also a comedian and she's at the Comedy
Store a lot this is this is the contest
for laughs or something how dare you
demean those call but yeah yeah it's
called the tits for Taliban no stupid
with you know it's called USO proper
military to where we all a dumb girl
name I've always called tits for life I
think there are tours and I
yeah it's like we're the slutty mommy's
slutty mom was funny funny
Belcher's females alright tits and
giggles it's so bad and I've listened I
did one and I did one and I swore to
myself I would never do like a girl tour
like that with a dumb fucking name like
that I would never do it again
because it's the meaning I'm a fucking
comic I'm not a tits and giggles I agree
you cocksuckers anyways no I'm going the
Middle East
I'm gonna go they don't tell you where
and too far in advance because of
security and I'm not even allowed to
tweet where I am at the time I have to
tweet after the fact because of security
so you can't say where you're going I
can't say where I'm going you in right
now and I won't for security reasons you
shouldn't because breach those things
I'm nervous
okay the weather more than anything it's
like 140 there you're going in the Sun
oh my mother can't st. and good boy
well it's one of the things we wanted to
talk about you know we're very cultured
people where we've traveled a lot
travelled the world I like museums
Stanley likes cartoons but I like
museums Cuba I did go to Cuba I don't
know if I talked about it on the fucking
crazy yeah I went to Guantanamo Bay did
you get waterboarded no you get to
waterboard someone yeah of course you'd
let everybody do that no it was pretty
rad that was um that was an amazing
experience
that was an amazing experience to go to
basically a place that you know you
can't go to it's amazing nobody can
really where they're like giant rats
banana rats man those things are
enormous look at banana rat online and
it is horrifying we may have I don't
know but that was an amazing experience
oh yeah yeah okay well I know I didn't
get to but you could see from the top of
one of the hills you can see the
different camps the camps the prisoner
camps that are obviously
I was in the news and initially the
reason they were gonna close Guantanamo
Bay when Obama took office which they
never he never did you know we're
colleagues
no he didn't Khalid Sheikh Mohammed and
a bunch of other terrorists and then a
bunch of people who have never been
charged with anything where they're all
kept is there you can you can bay from a
distance see them from the top of the
hill it's it's that also leaves a pretty
crazy on you well I think anytime is a
civilian you get to be privy to you know
shit that most people will never see
them it's it's sad and it's scary edible
to be a part of it military the kid mo
kind of you know it because of what came
to what we handle learn about what goes
on there you know it it it really kind
of effects you oh sure to know that like
there are people that are even at that
time were six years there without being
charged with anything and they're in
you're in a legal limbo it's it's it's
kind of so and then it's also impressive
to see that Gitmo is it's much bigger as
far as it's much more than you expect
that prisoner stuff is like I said it's
out of out of sight beyond the hill you
can't see it from anywhere else on base
and base is huge there are thousands of
enlisted people living on base and
there's schools middle school high
school there are stores restaurants
something where Castro overlooks that
base
yeah something didn't you tell me that
yes there um there's a restaurant like a
famous restaurant up on the hill like
you know there used to be at the height
of Cold War they had you know like
Marines were posted up everywhere along
the perimeter like every however many
yards 20 yards there was tanks and our
Marines and then across the you know Lou
whatever the line there was the Cuban
equivalent and they would mirror each
other and
it was very hostile and Castro had like
a restaurant that he would take
dignitaries visiting to and the whole
thing was that he had the restaurant
belt high up on this hill so his whole
thing was that I looked down on the
Americans on this base well guess what
Castro you can suck it cuz we look down
on you
you know why America's number one number
one Tommy that's right Castro is a
fucking asshole he's a piece of human
garbage the biggest asshole in the world
is well there's a there's some big ones
but um for anybody that's wondering Hugo
Chavez is a piece of shit he's a
horrible human being he is a dictator
unlike with Shawn Danny Glover say that
he's a you know that he's a elected if
he's not an elected official he's a
dictator he was systematically ruining
the lives of people in Venezuela and if
you knew anything about it if he weren't
invited to the presidential palace you
might have a clue Chavez has shut down
all forms of media you can't there are
it's only state-run media now if you
criticize Chavez all of a sudden you
disappear
you have anything negative to say about
the government that's it you're gone
what you know just normal democratic
stuff like that there's hundreds of
people that have disappeared and by the
way Chavez is form of you know for the
people's socialism it works like this
oh you're rich oh you you you have nice
things you have a nice home I'm gonna
take your home and I'm gonna give it to
these six peoples are here that's his
that's his his you know is really
open-minded and warm philosophy for
letting everybody thrive and Venezuela
it's just taking from those that have
killing them or expelling them
supporting them and giving those that
don't it's really cool any manipulates
of course the poor and uneducated into
thinking he is a champion he's a
complete dictator
a piece of shit is when celebrities like
Sean Penn and like you said Danny Glover
they go over and they get this royal
treatment well why doesn't Sean Penn go
and entertain troops on an oil tanker in
between Iran and Iraq in the middle of
the fucking ocean okay
why doesn't Sean Penn go and see what
people are really doing in the world
he's not he said he's an elitist
celebrity and he's not one of us he
hasn't been one of us since he was how
old since 18 years old since he did Fast
Times at Ridgemont the guy has not been
a normal human being are you doing on
Fast Times at foot or his sequel.fast
times at foot fuck hi Matt's been
informing me is one of his new favorite
movies that's how dare you bring that up
in the middle of my important read know
it it is I find it extremely infuriated
to hear somebody like him say I've been
there
you've been a Hugo Chavez his
presidential palace you fucking asshole
and you're gonna tell us no no I talked
to him he really is an elected leader no
he's not those those are manipulated
fraudulent elections heat by the way
changed
he put up to vote um that he could be uh
so the president could be elected for
like four lightly could be keep winning
elections instead of having term limits
and it was it was voted down they would
they vote against it so you know what he
did he said we're gonna put it on the
ballot again and guess what it passed
the second time Cowen's I know it is a
really coincidental it's very
coincidental yeah where were you leading
to before and I really I don't know what
were there - I was gonna say oh well he
probably falls into this category and
that is that we we've always kind of
been fascinated by you know people of
different mentalities and particularly
those who are capable of doing anything
and everything without feeling anything
about it and those are commonly referred
to as
sociopaths and I started reading this
book called the sociopath next door
which is really fascinating and I highly
recommend if you listen to this show to
go get a copy of that it really it
highlights what it what a sociopath is
and how common it is and essentially
what the this the book is written by a
very accomplished psychologist a woman I
can remember her name but essentially
what a sociopath is somebody who has no
conscience whatsoever they never feel
guilt or shame and to somebody that does
like most of us do you we can't
comprehend it like it's it's never ever
ever feeling badly or empathy they lack
empathy but the main thing is that you
have no conscience whatsoever you and
now sociopaths differ from Psychopaths
because sociopaths can learn to mimic
like the behavior of somebody like they
they go oh like people with a conscience
go oh I feel really badly about that you
know and they they see that that's what
people do so they learn to mimic that
you can be tricked more much more easily
by a sociopath and a psychopath a
psychopath doesn't have that ability
they don't learn to read that stuff and
they just well also I think sociopaths
what they have in common with people
with like Asperger's is that they can
read and mimic emotional cues like I
once talked to a guy with Asperger's and
I was like you don't seem like you have
it and he's like yes because I've
learned to read the human face and I've
learned what an emotional response looks
and sounds like which is really right
and that's what sociopaths and and the
other thing that the - two of the more
fascinating things about the sociopaths
are that a how common it is and how
and hell how little it's discussed it's
so common that it's basically 1 in 25
people and that is a higher
statistically higher than eating
disorders which you think about how come
and it is to discuss eating disorders
and nobody talks about socialize because
it's harder to study maybe they can't I
think it's just so she perhaps no
they're sociopaths and whereas the nice
thing you know you're that's a great
question I think that over time they
recognize that everybody around them is
a certain way they realize that they are
I think over time yeah I think other
people realize that you're so Tom pushed
over a little kid and he started
laughing maybe something like Tom
watches a movie like happiness or Henry
portrait of a serial killer and he
starts laughing at the scene where the
prostitute gets murdered
is it that funny scene but here's here's
the thing yeah oh the other thing one of
the great misconceptions and this is
actually something I've always wondered
about sociopaths and and and this book
explains it very well is that being a
sociopath has nothing to do with being
violent you know the like it's not like
a sociopath is violent it's that
somebody who's a sociopath can be prone
to violence and have zero guilt or
remorse about violence but there's also
a sociopath who have zero violence in
them they just don't feel guilty or
remorse about anything that they do
oh and those people get into showbiz
that's the thing is that sociopaths have
tremendous egos they love the feeling of
power some sociopaths are ambitious
intelligent driven and they can conquer
and feed that ego but a sociopath
doesn't necessarily have to be of great
intellectual capacity so
could be somebody who's just you know
very capable very little and that person
as a sociopath may just get joy out of
being basically abusive to his employees
at the place we all didn't we all worked
with someone like or I mean Hitler look
Hitler flunked out of art school you
know he was a failed art student and he
wasn't a great mind he was not in fact
he was extremely pretty average and to
intellect same with all of his henchmen
him where Eichmann
does that like was were you attracted
you think to working for him with you
when like was he able to charm you
Hitler was pretty fun guy to hang out
with Tom you don't know the Hitler I
know you better not walk into Lars von
Trier territory mmm-hmm which one's it
which ones that he's the man this is
great
the the Dutch director is a very
talented director this guy was a
sociopath
no what are you talking about yes no
Lars von Trier I'm trying to tell the
story
what film the movie about the guy and he
them rape and I murdered a member right
Pedro almodvar sorry I'm sorry
lars von trier you didn't know about
this no I can a few weeks ago he's at
can he's with just at a new film with
Kirsten Dunst right - is that it's just-
yeah so he's doing panel and he just
goes I mean Cisco's yeah you know I
thought it was a Jew I'm not a Jew I'm
actually a Nazi and then he just and I
think people are like huh and then for
him Nazi like he says was like that's
what we call German turns out that he
has German blood and then he just goes
from that thought he goes yeah so I can
really understand Hitler like I kind of
sympathize with him like I mean he's
he wasn't a good guy she says that he
wasn't a good guy but yeah I can
understand in a lot of ways and then
everyone's like huh-huh
and you can see Kirsten fences neck so
it's great she reacts she goes yeah yeah
she's like what are you doing and then
he tries to dig himself out of it it
just goes horribly and then the next day
they kicked him out I can they're like
you can't be here man I love it I love
when liberal art people like quote
unquote you know the same people that
support that a-hole that raped
thirteen-year-old girl what's his name
Opel Lance Polanski the same way this a
whole Hollywood community rallies around
child molesters because it's hip you
know what I mean like I'm not saying
that what that guy said large we're
interested it's correct it's not but so
what
let him be crazy that's what Hollywood's
about isn't it we into Free Cities kind
of insane that like what the guy said is
terrible or and and it's not it's not
defendable anyway but it does say
something about the fact that you can
say something awful like that and they
go get out of here
but if Polanski wanted to go to that
festival they would be like absolutely
come on in Polanski you drugged and you
raped a girl when she was 13 oh but it
was so long ago it doesn't really matter
and she was asking for it because she
wanted to be in show biz so there you go
I have a real I take real issue with the
whole Polanski thing I mean here's
here's the the the biggest problem is
that people go well you know what he was
manipulated and lied to by the judge and
the judge told them that all he had to
do was XY and Z and then that the judge
was lying which could very well be true
it doesn't matter to me that that's the
reason like I care that the judge was a
fuckin like it sucks yeah that sucks man
a judge lied to you but the fact that
people can the only reason people defend
Polanski is because he is an amazing
filmmaker he's a tremendous director one
of the best of all time
that is without just being he is
tremendous we don't we would not ever
defend the man if he were a fucking a
donut shop owner if he were a teacher
object if he were a fucking firefighter
if he ran a business of any kind
everybody would feel completely
comfortable labeling him human garbage
because these were tremendous artists we
all go well it's part of his art sweetie
he's eccentric but Lars von Trier makes
an off-color comment which by the way
he's not raping little girls he just has
a fucked up point of view and and I
thought that's what we stood for in the
art community and I'm being artists his
free speech so I don't agree with lars
von trier but to kick him out it seems a
little fucking ridiculous just I mean
that's just it's all bullshit that's an
act it's liberal anyways anyways back to
the sociopaths
Oh sociopaths yeah we know a few of
those I think the whole point is that
when you read this book now I don't even
finish it yet but when you read the book
you start it shows you so many little
things so many cues about them you
realize how many of them are in your
life
really what are some cues like yeah but
it goes into more than that but I'm
saying you start to realize I mean the
book like I said highlights that there
ever were there in your lair you know
they're like I said they're manipulators
they're charming they can be charming
they they have the you know the ability
like that they have the ability to just
fit in and they're they're essentially
evil people you know yeah are capable of
capable yeah I guess what constitutes
evil is the lack of empathy the lack of
emotion the lack of giving a fuck for
your fellow man I guess could constitute
evil sure drinking no no I think my
stepdad was you do I think it's some
form and he was a bit of a
shy stir and a character and he would
get into fights with people and parking
lots of bonds it was pretty crazy
yeah I think I think look one in four
people has herpes and one in twenty five
people are sociopaths it's one in five
for our Peas 1 in 5 for our peas and
then one in 25 that's tough dating
that's a lot of people it's actually so
much where and warrants - everyone has
warrants yeah it's actually so much
where I mean I guess I'm not having it
you go I really don't want that but
apparently the people I've talked to
some people that have it and they're
like yeah it's really not a big deal
which is you gotta go that's it I guess
it's not if everybody if one in five
people has it I hope you don't think
it's a big deal
not yet no weightless trip is gonna be a
great trip we got to wrap this up man
I know Chatty Cathy you are you are
listen I hope tonight you don't snore
and I hope we don't have those goddamn
housekeepers keeping us that's fucking
rude way to know terrible way cuz
they're not even using their fucking
hands right like if you were to nose in
a car if you were about on on the door
like that to like a friend yeah with
that they'd be like hey asshole yeah you
don't have to do that with the fucking
key and make it sound so aggressive hi
mommies we got our fucking I love you I
love you too
you're the mommy you're the main mommy
will do another mom cats hopefully
tomorrow yes sir for sure tomorrow will
upload it to iTunes okay
all right bye mommies thank you for
listening
your your the main model